hello in this video we will start with
the question
what is a chi-square test and how do i
interpret
the results at the end i will show you
how you can easily
calculate the chi-square test online
with data tab
let's start when do we use the
chi-square test
the chi-square test is used when you
want to investigate
if there is a relationship between two
categorical
variables the question is what is a
categorical variable
categorical variables for example are
gender
with male and female the preferred
newspaper
for example the washington post new york
times
the u.s today or frequency of television
daily several times per week more really
or never
or the highest educational level no
categorical variable
is body size body weight or
the salary for example if we want to
investigate
the relationship between two categorical
variables
we need the chi-square test therefore
if we want to investigate if there's a
relationship
between gender or preferred newspaper
you need the chi-square test or
if you want to investigate gender and
frequency
of television if you want to investigate
if there's a relationship
between preferred newspaper and
frequency of television
or the last example if you want to
investigate
frequency of television and the highest
educational level
so always if you have two categorical
variables you need the chi-square test
in order to investigate
if there's a relationship between these
two
variables imagine we want to investigate
if there is a relationship
between gender and highest educational
level
for this purpose we simply do a small
survey
where we ask the people what the gender
is
and we ask them what the highest
educational level is
this questionnaire we will send randomly
to people
and all of them will answer this two
question
the outcome is this table where each row
is one
case so the first person is male
and the highest educational level is
college
the second person is female with the
highest educational level without
graduation this table can now be used
for a statistical software
like data tab if we copy this table into
data tab
data tab will give us these cross table
in this table you can see the two
categorical variables
at the one side you see the highest
educational level
and at the other side you see the
variable
gender each cell represents how often a
certain combination
occurs for example without graduation
and female we count six persons so
six persons in this table answered they
are female
and without graduation or seven person
answered they are male and without
graduation
so now the question is is there a
relationship between
gender and highest educational level
so is there a correlation between gender
and the highest level of education
in order to answer these questions we
simply use
the chi-square test now there are two
ways to calculate the chi-square
one way is to simply use a statistic
software like data tab
or you can calculate the chi-square by
hand and use
the critical value of the chi-square
table
i will start how you can easily
calculate the chi-square test
online with data tab in order to do this
please visit datatep.net
and then click on the statistics
calculator
if you want to use your own data you
need to clear
this table now you can copy your own
data
i have prepared these example data so
i simply select them and
copy them into this table
now because we want to calculate a
square test we simply click
on this tab and we want to investigate
the two variables gender and highest
educational level
therefore we simply click on gender and
highest educational level
because we select two categorical
variables
data tab will automatically calculate a
chi-square test
so here we can see the table of the
observed
frequencies so we see how often occurs
female and without graduation six times
or how often does male occur without
graduation seven times
in the table below you see the expected
frequency
for a perfectly independent variable so
if there's no connection or relationship
between gender and highest educational
level
this table would normally be the outcome
therefore we want to compare this table
with this table
and we can see the results here so in
this case
the p-value is 0.918
for sure this p-value is quite high and
for sure it is
higher than 0.05 our significance level
so in this case we will not reject the
null hypothesis
and the outcome is that there's no
relationship
between gender and the highest
educational level
so again we used data tab in order to
calculate
the results for the chi-square test the
outcome is that we have a p value of
0.981
and because this value is higher than
our significance level of 5 percent
we will not reject null hypothesis so
for p values smaller than 0.05
the null hypothesis is rejected
in our case we have a p value of 0.981
which is for sure higher than 0.0
and therefore we will not reject the
null hypothesis
and therefore there's no relationship
between gender and highest educational
level
and now i'd like to show you how you can
calculate the
chi-square test by your own here we can
see the table
of the observers frequencies further we
need
a table where we can compare the
observed frequencies
so we need the table of the expected
frequencies
in this case the expected frequencies is
a table
when the variables are perfectly
independent
so now we want to compare the observed
frequencies
with the expected frequencies
and we can calculate the chi-square
this we can do by simply using this
equation
what does it mean for this example for
example
we compare each cell of this table with
each cell
of this table so we choose
6 minus 6.08 divided by the
expected frequency 6.08
and then we take the next cell we
calculate
7 minus 6.92
squared divided by the expected
frequency of
6.92 and if we do this for all cells
we will get chi square of 0.504
so now we have calculated the chi-square
with 0.504 and we know the degree of
freedom
which is in this case three so it's the
number of rows minus one
times the number of columns number one
so we have
three times one which is 3
and now we can have a look
at the table of critical chi square
this table you can find at data tab
and because we have a significance level
of
five percent and we have a degree of
freedom of three our critical chi-square
value is 0.815
so because the calculated chi-square
value of 0.504
is smaller than the critical chi-square
value of
7.815 we will not
reject the null hypothesis so
we have the calculated chi-square value
and we have the critical
chi-square value and our calculated
chi-square value is smaller than the
critical value so we will not
reject the null hypothesis so the result
is the same
if we are using data tab or doing the
calculations
by hand if you like this video please
subscribe to our channel
and see you soon bye